Hello?
Can you guys see me?
I'm gonna refresh my own stream.
Staring contest stream.
Did it stream to the wrong thing? Cause I will cry.
I will. I'll cry right on my Twitter space. I'll cry all over everyone.
I'm gonna... I'm gonna cry.
Where is it?
It's not even showing that I'm live.
It's not even showing that I'm live. Please.
Oh my god, I just got jumped scared by a freaking ad.
Can you guys hear me?
I'm just a face in the void.
This looks so freaking cursed.
I just...
I don't understand.
Oh my god.
Okay, let me hook up my phone.
Let's just...
Please.
I beg of you.
It's showing that I have... I'm wearing white.
It's literally just a black void.
And I'm just staring.
Did the Twitter space die?
Did it die?
Oh my god, did the Twitter space just die?
Hello?
Are you guys still here?
Can I do both at the same time?
Okay, I'm gonna go bye.
Bye, Twitter space.
Unless you want two of me at the same time.
That sounds weird.
Okay, bye.
Stay classy, my friends.
I...
I have a lot to atone for.
What?
One pauses.
I have to switch screens, so if I do this, then I'm like, hi.
I'm a floating head.
Hi there.
Hi.
Welcome to the void.
And then...
Okay, I got a burp.
Okay, bye.
Bye.
Oh my god.
This is working.
Okay.
Can you hear me?
Let's try to boot up.
Do maternal.
I can't fucking plug in my phone.
Can you hear me fine?
Okay.
I feel like...
What is floating next to my head?
What is that?
It's like a white dot.
Who are you?
Wait, it's the blanket.
How did that happen?
I was wondering where the blanket went.
Because I'm like, where did the blanket go?
It's right there.
And then there's the back of the blanket.
And then there...
I don't know what that is.
What's that blue thing?
I...
Oh, it's my controller.
Isn't that controller?
It's right there.
It's this blue dot.
You can barely see.
Oh my god.
Guys, I can't handle this.
I can see how amazing my rigging is,
even with just the head.
Wow.
I look like I'm part of a YouTuber showcase
where I'm just showing all my angles.
Okay.
It might as well put the blanket on.
Hold on.
I can't see what you guys are saying.
Let me just make the screen smaller.
Yippee.
That's the world's smallest blanket.
So, head.
Shiba, you are a beautiful mess.
I...
I don't know what to do.
Okay.
I try my best out here.
And at least the stream is still working.
You know?
Like, honestly, I'm pretty impressed.
Let's put on some clothes, shall we?
Let me just...
Yippee.
Yahoo.
Oh, yeah.
My neck looks so orange.
Hey.
Wait, no, now I'm all over the place.
This isn't gonna work, guys.
I don't know what to do.
My neck is really orange.
It doesn't matter if you're late.
It's literally just been scuffed, brother.
B2 shooting is better glue.
I agree with this because, like, I don't know what it's exactly attaching to,
but I don't know.
You'd think that, like...
I don't know.
I don't know how.
If I stay like this, I look fine.
Now you can take as many screenshots as you want,
because I'm so cute.
Mmm.
I can't wink with my other eye that well.
What the shivity?
Ah, see?
I forgot that my mouth can move all the way over there.
Ah.
Ah?
Hot and cute.
Refling, oh, hi.
Hi, reflings.
Like, 300 people just got dumped in my chat,
and I'm just a loser.
Can't read it, can't read it, can't read it.
Nothing's working.
So I'm just sitting here.
Hold on, let me try to open up.
DOOM.
Nope, that's not Steam, that's Discord.
What happened?
I'm literally gonna cry, guys.
Oh my...
Hold on, I need to put on my crying emoji for this.
So...
I look like I'm about to do an apology video.
I look like I'm about to do an apology video,
and also my chat isn't working on screen.
I'm really identifying with the reflings right now,
I think I'm in a puke.
So, you know how...
my internet has been going in and out for the past few days?
Should I get a ukulele?
Do I have any instruments?
Do I have any, I will...
I don't think I have any instruments.
Oh, I do.
I don't even remember why I have these maracas, but I have maracas?
I don't know why.
I don't know why I have a maracas PNG.
So you guys know how my internet has been going in and out.
For...
the last few days, and stream has been weird, and so have my calls.
Do me turn, I'll never finish downloading!
And only downloaded 34 gigs!
I never finished!
And I open up Steam and it doesn't say, oh, any downloads are queued!
It's over, bros! I'm so sorry I let you down!
It's literally 34 out of 78 gigs downloaded,
because I was literally about to go click play,
and I, you know, I played Elden Ring today,
and it doesn't say anything downloads are queued,
or nothing's paused, or whatever.
It's chip over!
I need a maracas noise.
This is not maracas, it's me shaking food.
Chick, chicky, boom, chick, chicky, boom, chick, chicky, boom.
Why do I have, what else do I have?
What other weird PNG, well you guys know I have, like, a gun.
Wait.
Oh, I think I remember.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, yeah, that's hehehehe.
Hold on, wait, did I ever change the color of the skin tone on this?
Guys! I'm, I'm so sorry.
I forgot that it does that!
I just wanted to look like I was moving or sitting down!
Now they're really gonna think I'm a whore!
I'm sorry.
No, that's too many!
How does it, oh and I move my mouse upwards.
I thought, wait.
What?
Wait a second.
Wait, what?
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
What?
Wait a second.
No, I'm not one of those streamers, where did my pants go?
My eyes are burning.
I just hurt my nose.
I just scratched my nose with my nail.
I'm falling apart.
And you're laughing at me.
And you're laughing.
Can I stop crying?
Okay, now I can sweat.
Hello, Raifling.
Somebody take this away.
Somebody take it away from me.
Somebody...
I just meant the legs.
You know what?
I think I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna end it all.
Hold on.
Pretend that this is a building.
Okay, you guys stay with me.
Stay with me.
Stay with me here.
No.
Okay, pretend this is a building and not a casting couch.
And that this is lava?
All right.
It's boiling lava.
Okay.
And then, naturally, I'm a G, so I gotta wear these.
Sure.
Can I please stop attaching to me?
Oh, my... help.
Help.
Okay.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna do it right now.
Tell me.
Tell me I won't.
What is on my... what is that?
Oh, wait, no, that's on my screen.
I thought there was something on my face.
Goodbye.
Wait, I just made myself smaller.
Wait, hold on.
Wait, no.
Flip.
Ah!
In the arms of an angel
An angel
Wait!
That's so hard to do!
Where am I?
No, that's so hard to do!
Help me.
I can't breathe.
Help.
Okay, I'm back.
I'm so sweaty.
Wow, wow, wow.
Wait, can I make a tiny body for myself?
Wait, no, I have a better idea.
Sorry, I still have the reverb on.
Okay, don't worry, guys.
I can fix this.
Wait, no, that won't work.
I'm making a little body for myself.
Okay.
Wait, no.
Don't, don't, just let me, let me cook.
Let me cook.
Why are people membering?
Did somebody donate?
What's wrong with you?
Shabee is a piece of furniture.
I thought that was her job.
Thank you.
All right, all right, all right.
I'm making myself a little body.
Thank you.
Would you love me if I was a worm?
No, I just drew that in Canva
Can I can I carry a bazooka I don't have a bazooka
Why do you think I would commit so many acts of violence just kidding I would
You thought we were playing you thought we weren't gonna play doom you're the demon now
I
I'm sorry
I have to do what I must
Don't put your forehead against my trigger against the barrel
Okay
I love you so much. I didn't want to do this to you
But the brain worms are winning because I'm one of them now and this is all that's left of me
I can't let you go the same way
Wait, hold on please hold for this skit hold on please hold
I'm actually crying. I'm getting too much into it. Please hold hold on
Perfect
You know what this is good enough. No, it's not
Oh my god, please. I can't move fast enough. My hands are too slow. My tummy hurts because I had cheese
How I can't paste
Perfect I did it
But can I find the image is the question because I didn't save it as a different name
Um
Okay for the sake of this skit
Pretend
That this
Is a bullet. Okay. Just just just roll with me here
That you only meant well well, of course you did mm. Whatcha say, please she be don't pull the trigger on the vod
Whatcha say
No, I don't mean well
Well, well, of course you did so you're being shot in the face right now the bullet's coming closer to you
The bullet's so close. You've just been killed
Do you get it you get it, right? Okay, I'm gonna put that away
Uh
Why do I
Wait, hold on. I have an idea. I can't see chat. So I don't even know what's going on
I'm so sorry, uh, but we will be continuing the meme because I actually think I quite like being worm
You
Wait, no, this is
Ah
I just wanted you have little noodle arms
I don't want it. No, let me get cancelled
I just wanted to be a fucking noodle
Oh
I'm gonna get in troubles Johnny's gonna hate me
No, I'm gonna turn myself
Help me
Okay
That's better
Am I okay, I'm fine. I'm just tired tired of my own bullshit. Okay, um
Let's do another one
You
This is what I come up with
When I
When a game isn't working
This isn't no, this is what comes with the model. I look like a tree
You know what you know what I think you should do
Come close come no come closer. I need you to thank you
I need you
To make like a tree
And grow and prosper as a person
Okay, that's what I want you to grow
Like a tree
Uh-huh, can you do that for me?
This is now an inspirational video. This is now motivational
Did you think did you wake up one day and thought you would only be ahead?
Incorrect
With the power
Of anything
You can do anything it looks like I have a wee wee is fine. Thank you for this beautiful stream
I am here to tell you that you can be anything you want
You want to be a tree tree? You want to be a dog?
You want to be a cat meow? All right
Don't ask why I don't have any legs. I'm working on it. Just give me a moment
You know how long this takes me to do it takes me a minute. Okay. That's very long time
And
I can't believe I made myself into a swatka. I'm actually gonna
Permit
Now I now I look like
I
Please
Is that what you wanted are you not interested
Thank you for the gifted
Oh
Oh, you can't catch me you can't catch me you can't catch me
I was like the banana from
Oh
Anyways, if you like this content, please sure to hit the subscribe button down below. It really helps me out a lot
Make sure that you follow me on twitter and on
Patreon and you can get more content just like this, especially on twitter
I hope you guys had a really good time
I'm kidding. It's not over
You thought it was done. No bitches
Is
I'm getting period cramps and I don't know why
This is the content you signed up for
Okay, uh, do you think I could put like I think I can give myself clothes
To dinner first
Benji tipped six dollars and ninety cents. Oh great and powerful triby. Do you think
Possibly you may grow old and wise like myself at some point in time
It is debatable, but it's possible
Help
Hello, hello
Can you help me up
Help
Help me
Guys, it's really dark and scary
And I don't know what to do
Help
I don't know what's happening
I think I'm transforming vtube studio is broken. Oh my god. What's up?
Uh
Um
I I may have pressed the wrong button
What oh, yeah, let's cover up
Oh
Um, oh
Yeah, let's sit and talk in the void shall we?
Did you think you were safe
You're never safe from me
Never
I can see you I can smell you
You smell
Stinky
Oh, that's not what I wanted. Don't worry about that
It reminds you of talking to Monica
It's just me
It's just she be
I have had now hold on I need to spin it
I
Don't be afraid
It's me boy to she be
I'll be here with you forever
Don't worry about a thing hold on I need to get my mouth perfect
Are you amazed are you
You're falling deeper and deeper and love with me
Nothing
Can escape me in the void
You are with me forever
You will never leave me
You will
Buy the property on the railroad in monopoly and buy a can of Pringles while you're at it
Sorry, I need you to clear my throat
Strong he's not the only one with hypnotist powers you're getting
Hope hold on
I can't
I
Can't get them to stick
Wait
You
What the fuck
My eyes are down
It's like a game you have to use the physics to line up the glasses
No
And then there was us just me
It paused again
I forgot I was like this
It's it's not letting me all I'm streaming. It's not letting me download doom. It's saying it's gonna take an hour
I don't even
I'm not even gonna bother man
I'm a pokemon
And I'm also on a list because I'm my dingling out. Yeah
This is the content you guys wanted
This is all I got I don't
I just wanted to put my schedule together and I can't even
$4 and 20 cents never thought mr. Freaking go would make an appearance during a doom stream
Mr. Freaking go
Wait, hold on. Is there like an online doom I can play
Doom online
Hold on I have to watch an ad you guys don't need to hear it though. I'll save you
You
Perfect I got guys I figured it out hold on
What the heck is happening
It froze
The doom emulator froze
And my whole entire computer is frozen. I don't even know if I'm streaming anymore
It's not an emulator. It's just an online browser game. I'm sorry
Please don't come for me
If you do that, that'd be kind of weird
Anonymous tip two dollars you can play doom through the xbox app if you have game pass you think I have game pass
Look at me. Do I look like the type of person to have xbox game pass?
No
That'd be funny if I was like, yeah, I do good idea
I
Can't click anything my mouse is gone
Oh my god, what is okay, get me out of here get me out of here get me out of here
Is this just like hacking my computer
I
It's auto playing
Hold on I'll show you guys
Don't worry. I'm I'm doing it you may not be able to see it but it's there
Wow, I'm doing so good
Crazy
Hold on I need to get into character further
All right, you guys ready I move myself over here
All right, I'm doing pretty good
I'm just using a mouse. Is this it?
How do I get out of here how why does this look like a bodice? It looks like
Oh
I'm on episode three. I don't even know what that means. Do I reload?
Just kidding
You
Start from episode one. How the hell do I do that?
You guys are asking a lot of me
Can I just refresh the page
I'm the professional is this knee deep in the dead is that it?
No, I'm not downloading the game my computer can't handle anything right now
Hey, not too rough
Oh, oh, okay. I have to fart guys. I have to fart. Uh
Oh god, you can't hear it. My blanket is muffling my fart. Okay, cool
What type of game is this?
Oh
Shit hell, yeah
I'm gonna tell you right now this music is fucking bopping
Oh, it's a door I came from how do I get out?
I think he's dead
Oh, this is great
What are these what am I picking up? Oh armor bonuses
I need to turn on the music though for me
I'm freaking amazing can I scope in? No
When did you come out?
Grab a shotgun
How do I change
Ask my dad that's a good. I should probably I can't text him right now
Is this an elevator?
Help
Oh shit, I
Okay, but those looked like dudes some of them look like normal guys
I
What's that mean
What is par 30 set what's par did I this is golf?
There's zombie soldiers
Don't call them that they look like nice guys
They were possessed it's a speedrun game
Par time you're talking like I know what that means
Oh, it took that it took me 30 seconds psych
Oh, oh they do look like zombies
Nice
I need a key
Is that a door what the hell?
Oh, what the okay
I shot him in the booty cheek
It's an elevator guys this is hard
I don't think I'm smart enough for this game
Oh, is that the key get freaked
Yeah, let's go
Hold on
Yeah, I can't tell him why my bullet spread is but it's amazing
Okay
Let's go
I can't get out there help
Take me up
Oh 360
What are these health bonus?
Oh, it's acid. Oh guys. I think that's acid
It's a secret. Oh, I'm not gonna find it. Oh my god
I got him I have 200 armor
Yeah, buddy
100 health
This music is awesome
Let's go. Let's tango brothers strafe. Can I open the door strafe? Oh, I'll get actually got
Shock on cell shell. I can't like aim downwards
He has no knees
Oh vertical aim bot
Oh
What
I have good ad movement. Thank you
I have infinite height in doom. Oh, I didn't know this that's where I came from. Yeah
Oh buddy who wants to tango?
Who's moaning you?
Ow
I don't recommend shooting those that's just a word of advice
Just
A word of who is moaning?
Is it you?
I'm like floating across the ground
This is great. I'm actually enjoying myself
They do have infinite height what the frick that's so odd
I
This is doom eternal. I don't know what you're talking about. I need health
Yippie
I'm gonna fall off this platform. Oh, they're fighting each other. Oh, I could just third party him. Let's go
Am I like move? Oh, I don't even mean to move back. I can play with just a mouse
To move forward. Oh, that's so weird
If I want to go forward, I just move my mouse forward. What that's so odd
Oh
Blue keycard for the blue door what's happening? I didn't know this is a horror game
You think I would have a muzzle flash
Where's that
Okay, oh
Oh
Where do I go now? Hey guys, I can't see
Oh, I figured it out. Don't worry
What is that noise?
Go back. Oh
Oh
Help me guys
Or is there a ladder I think I saw a ladder
Are you sure it looked like there was a ladder next to me
Oh, it's saved did it. I don't fucking know. I don't think it did
Nope
Let's tango how 360 no scope
You got more armor. Why am I growling?
These are very forgiving
Ow
Where did I go before I think I went this way
And then I did that and then I don't remember what I did
Huh
I got yeah, buddy. You thought you could mess with the tree be you thought incorrectly
Why is it blinking morse code at me?
I'm not trying to walk forward, please
No, you guys are third partying each other before
Hell
I'm bleeding
My noise it says oh wait what
I
Can't move forward. What is that? It's like a button. Oh, that's probably the secret now banana
Oh
Blue key card
Ah, that scared me
Okay
And then it wants me to go this way
Guy the spooky
I'm almost dead. I can't fall again
Unless I jump in on purpose
Oh no
He was getting me hold on there's health back here
Where is it
These two dudes don't respond
Okay
Yeah, let's go
Oh
I'm missing
Yep
Why are you attacking him randomly?
Cool so I just leave the same white, okay
Oh
This is great. I'm enjoying myself. I don't know what I'm doing, but it's fun. I don't really know what to say
Well, I'm doing this what's that noise
Hit the barrel hit the barrel strafe
Oh
Nifty
Yeah, buddy
That noise is imps. I don't know what a imp is
I'll fight each other interesting I was supposed to do that in two minutes
I
Two minutes
Hope you're dancing with me
So
YouTube why did you go to a horror to 4 4? Oh, no, it's my internet going. It's my internet going
It's fine
I'm here. Okay. I got scared
Let's go boys
Wow
That is so cool
Did you see that
Oh, shit. Um
I am half health my shifty eyes
This level is big. I'm so sure. Oh, what's that?
Is there a guy I thought I heard a dude
Wow, I shot him through the floor
Ha, okay, can I have health?
Please I am I feel like I'm running on ice
Pimp better better better, what is that? Can't pick it up
Oh
No, hey a blue key. Well, I got a blue key the last time
Ow, what the fuck? Where'd you come from? I'm so close to death
Oh, okay, thank you
Oh
Damaging green goo for new kage like bukake
Shields from toxic goo
Oh
Why you guys up there? Oh, that's where I came from. Okay. Yeah
You see that
nasty
Disgusting
Can I pick that up? What is that?
That looks like health. Oh, it's pistol ammo. Okay
I couldn't tell I sound like I'm growling. It's kind of cute. I know it's him though
This name is fun
They should they should like remake this game. I'm stuck
Hail
Oh
It's a trick door, haha, uh-huh was a trap. It's called doom 2016. Hmm. I don't know never heard of it
Mine goo what is this water what?
Oh what
What did I get a mini gun? Oh my god
Oh something tells me I should go around this way
How do I raise the platform I need a yellow key
I jump oh damn
Okay, that's the exit
Is that the yellow key over there
Stop
Sick. Oh, how do I get over there?
Oh
I got the blue key finally didn't even realize
Ha ha ha
What the I'm getting dizzy I'm getting so motion say
There's so many toxic barrels what's happening
What happened to everyone? What's the lore? I don't know any doom guy lore
I heard it's really interesting and fucked up. Oh, that's convenient
Oh, look at this
You see that
Oh
Hell yeah
Okay, I was supposed to be a bit at 30. That's fine
Local man is angry to this too angry to die
The demons kill his rabbit
I'm literally in hell, but there's a lot of like man-made stuff here
Like what's the on a mars base?
Doom guy is a space marine on mars and they opened up portal the hell demons killed his pet rabbit and he's pissed
You're joking and they actually killed his pet rabbit
It's not a choke
Oh
Her name was daisy
Oh my god, my relative they killed on daisy
Don't touch a man's rabbit
Daisy was giving the doom guy to help treat his home
I think killed her
That's a travesty
Oh, hi gnarly
Hi my
I can't believe they did that
Ah
Oh
Buddy
Let's go down here first
Oh, there's not a shotgun that's so cool
Hmm
Why are there candles?
Mowing bitches down, what are you?
I'm happy I did that from this side that would have sucked
Oh, is that?
Spray and pray boys spray and pray and go there in a second
I think I got them you guys think so
There's another spot over here
That's where I came from
Hmm
Is that the only place left to go? I feel like I'm missing a spot or whatever. I
Don't know why it sounds like the drones from
Star Wars to me that noise
Get dead brother
What is that noise oh
Secret tada don't need it
I'm nasty sick nasty oh
What the heck it was all a trick
Okay, I need that health
Oh
Give me up Scotty
What that yippie
No, oh no, okay, it's fine
Oh
Nice
I got it
You jump scared me pal
Okay
Don't know what that does
I didn't see the exit
Where's the exit I
Already been there help it's gonna be like ten minutes
This is where I came from
Yeah, I was already over here I
Passed past the blue door, okay
But where where oh
I
Can't see I can't see I am gonna have a seizure help
What the fuck am I supposed I picked up a rocket
I
That's music is so good. I can't oh fuck I lost the door. Where is it?
Where's the exit? I lost it. Oh
God no, I picked up a rocket at least
How
I'm literally gonna go insane if I can't find this. Oh, what is that? Oh
Do I get night vision
Why does up with the sky why is it TV static?
Oh
Light amplification
Oh wait, you know what I should have done a long time ago
I
Know I didn't think of this oh
I found that I found the initial explosion this was supposed to be
The explosion of you getting pu pu'd but it's fine
I
Now you're tall is it boobs or is it a pee pee?
You'll never know
Wait, wait, I can give myself a dress
Hey, hold on
It's a dress my pee pee is sticking out from under my dress
It's
I
These are my apology maracas, and I'm sorry for the stream, okay
Are you not entertained
I
Want me put my dress back on
Actually, I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna step into something a little bit more comfortable
Let me step into something more comfortable
Yeah, yeah, it's as thick as a monster it's as thick as a monster can
I
See original doom not eternal. I don't know this is the real this is this is eternal. This is what are you talking about?
This is eternal
Somebody somebody to mods rip off his nutsack and feed it to the dogs
This peak doom I
I
Take some
It takes a monster to fight monsters
Oh wait, I have alcohol, you know it'd be a good idea adding alcohol to the mix I
Have a Mike's hard lemonade, and if you're not if you know around here
I
Give me a Mike's hard
Before I left the other day, she's like we don't really like these you want on on Mike
Yeah, sure. She's like you want the whole thing, and I'm like no
So I don't drink
Yeah, see you can see the crucible. It's right there. Oh
Oh, this tastes good. It is a hard lemonade seltzer strawberry
Never mind it doesn't taste good
I'm still gonna drink it cuz I just I don't like wasting things I'm fine
I
Should play yellow and ring like this
Yeah, the seltzer get some seltzer ASMR
I
Take some monster to fight monsters cuz I want to do that like it's just me with a monster can on my body and
Just put me on a t-shirt like this
Wait no, hold on
There you go
All right, let's continue
Later I need to check this
I
Sorry I'm messaging Amy cuz Amy is wondering how to add items from booth
So this is very serious conversation. Everybody act professional, please. I'm texting my little sister
Oh
9 out of 10, when am I gonna get 10 out of 10s?
I
All right, boys
Okay, all right boys
They move myself over no, I don't want to make my can bigger make myself bigger a
Chat's not working. Yeah, it's time
Bigger cans the wolf quest burpas 10 out of 10
The pin pals hand out 10 out of 10s to Amy all the time and to strongy you guys just fucking hate me
Okay, let's fucking admit it
The way you guys rebel for me not being dumb enough is you give me
9 out of 10s
That tastes like
Doesn't taste good. I'm still gonna drink it though. I just had to taste of alcohol
Oh
It's a lot of doors a lot of doors
This water or just blue carpet I
Didn't see you I
Have to far. I'm so focused on tooting
Oh
Hi
Can I not can I not double up on armor that's dumb
And I'm back to the grinds of pumping guys we're pumping them
Pump them I need a yellow key this bullshit
It is bullshit
See the bowl and then their shit is bullshit
Yeah
Ow ow, I did not mean
To who is shooting me you
You shot me through the wall it's like I could shoot you through the floor. Oh my god, there's so many of you
I wish I had the chain gun, but I don't know how to switch guns
It doesn't let me I'm at 19 health
No, wait, can I go back to the original spot I wasn't before
Cuz there's a lot of health stuff
Yeah
There's more health
Yeah, let's go buddy
No, let's go fuck some hose up
Wait, where's the door and I walked past it guys I'm actually stupid
There's also health right next to me
Guys I have a terrible sense of direction how
Others like literally giant shit's fucking health next to me
I
Don't miss all that health. I don't recall this is where I came from
Help why am I stupid
Here it is
Oh, why not jump scare me
Is burped but I was really small
No, no
Oh, can I go back up I don't know what this is
Super charge what the fuck does that mean?
Um, how do I get back up? Oh, I figured it out
What is that oh, I don't I don't know what the house going on
I generally don't know what I'm doing
Yeah, dude when turtle this is do maternal I don't know what you guys are talking about wait no
I want to go kill that guy
Yeah, bitch you're lucky. I can't tea bag
Wait, why am I cloaked?
Do I go down there oh
No, this is where I was before
I picked up partial invisibility. Well, it's gone now
Where the frick am I supposed to go
It's over there
Scared me it's not very nice
I
Already went there
It's like I whip and I get turned around
Is it the yellow key thing over here?
Brothers I don't know where to go
Tab shows map what
I
Trying to move on the map without looking
It's like over
Oh
This is where it was I just totally kept forgetting that this is where the yellow car key thing
Did I not pick up a yellow key
I
So now top-down game I'm going this way
All right now we're getting somewhere
This is a lot of rooms
How's everybody supposed to finish this in like five minutes not like are like two minutes make that make sense
Oh
And I already over here fuck you
I
Got
Where are you coming from
No, I went over here
This just takes you in a circle doesn't it oh what the hell
Bro what
Oh
Wait do I have it now
I'm killing myself. I'm killing myself. I'm killing myself. I'm gonna do it in front of everybody
I'm going to do it
Thank you. Thank you for giving it to me. I appreciate it
Oh
The hell what the hell that oh
Or did it fill out the map for me sick that's kind of kind of late though
Where's the fucking key
Dude
For real secrets
My cat is yelling and it scared me
The fuck did that do
There's like
Raina Raina
Okay, I'd love that
Raina why are you yelling
Guys where is the key
Where's the key
No, she just likes to yell when she has her favorite toy and let everybody know she caught something
The key is in our hearth or our hearts
Wait, I didn't know I could do that I can give myself buck teeth. Hey, how did I do that?
I can almost bite my lip
Fuck I can't do it again
How did I do that I feel like bite my lip almost
Guys I actually was able to bite my lip somehow
I mean my model was just glitching I don't even know where I'm going
I
As I give up I give up I can't do this. I'm too stupid for doom
What's this? Oh
Did I open a door? Oh, I found a yokey
I am not too stupid for doom
Help help he's snoring at me
That was terrifying I didn't think I was gonna survive that
That's not it
Is elevators are silly
No, please oh
No, oh
It's spooky what I hate you
What's happening there's too dark down here
Oh what the oh it just opens this door what
Am I special
Let me up
Is this just a door I can't open
Rain oh
She is hop on my lap
Oh
Why are there candles I don't get it
Raina you're stinky were you just in the litter box is that why you were oh, yes, you were
Go like your butt your butt's gross
That's why you were yelling
Oh
You're retelling everybody you took a shit
Stinky
Where'd I come from
Honestly you have to like follow the fucking growls. Oh, oh that was a switch. Oh, okay. That's what that did. Oh
I see
You know, this is pretty ingenious for the 1980s 60s 50s, I don't know what those mean no
Hi boo me
I was looking at my cats
I
Is more I'll kill all of you yes
I'll do it
I'll do it. I'll do it. No, please don't kill me
No, why aren't you dead? I have 14 health
Just get me out of here
Oh
Hey
That was unnecessary with the sound effects it is kept going
I call doom clones. Oh doom the game that started a console wars because it would make a game wait the tracks going to fast
I
Guys enjoying this is this amusing to you. Is this fun? Is this entertaining? I don't know you tell me I
Could take off my dress
Would you like to see what's under?
All right, you like the seduction music I got going in the background
Well, it's gone now
So when I click off the game it stops. Ooh
I'm showing a little shown a little bit more neck
Wait, I need put on I need put on my BGM for this
Oh
Showing you one show you the other
Are you seduced
Are you are you feeling seduced it's like a burlesque show
Let me show a little bit of leg oh not too much taste
I
Show a little bit of pee pee
Oh, I got my BGM wrong
Doesn't have any legs. I still got it wrong. Oh, don't you didn't see that I looked to the side I
Look how I talk a chat
It's getting smaller
I'm taking the maracas off
Put them right there taking the gloves off
Now you got you got a little bit of canned hands
Sips my dress you can't sip it. No, I
Won't get banned don't ban me. I know bitch. I know pussy
I
Get you going remember you can't you can't touch your Bible
Put your Bibles away
The Lord can't save you now sugar
Only I'm the one that you can raise you up
Oh
You
You wanna you don't take this to the blue website
I
That's kidding some of my audience members will be sad that I said I want to do more than one
I'm teasing you put your keyboard down
It's nothing it was a joke
I
People are asking like I was gonna do like 50 times Jesus Christ only want to do like one more extra time I
Can say whatever I want you can hate me you can impale me on your cans on your Bibles if you so please
Don't be jealous you can't have this you can't have this physique
You don't own me
But I own you
I
Imagine someone comes to stream right now and they're like oh it looks like she bees playing
Looks like she bees playing
retro
Doom like the OG doom and then I'm just like
Hey
This is quite
I
Want everybody to have a good time and be happy I want people to stress out
It makes me sad when I see a lot of people stress out at one spot and also my friends stress out
I don't want you to be stressed guys. Everything is gonna be fine
This is why I'm doing silly stuff today
This is why I streamed earlier in the morning cuz I just want to distract you guys from anything that might be making you upset or frustrated
I know things
May not make sense and you might wonder what the why is behind stuff, but please understand
um
But please understand that I am a worm now and you know, we have our growing we have our growing pains
Only kids don't worry about it. Don't worry about it. Oh, don't worry about it
I
Don't worry about it
Everything is gonna be fine. We still we're still learning and growing and adapting to the company. You might change your minds and do stuff
We're allowed to change our minds, you know
Adjust and make mistakes and we're just learning and we're growing everybody else. We're new. Okay
Let's go
Nineto thousand tensed tens all around. I'm gonna jiggle my balls in your face
I'm baldy go baldy go Baldy go ygo Baldy go Baldy go Baldy go Baldy go Baldy go Baldy go Baldy go Balty go Baldy go Baldy go Baldy go Baldy go Baldy go
You like that? Like me tea bag in you
But I just I just want everybody to be I think this is why I do silly fun stuff cuz I just want to make you happy
And I'm sad when people are sad and stressed out
don't worry everything's gonna be fine okay I know you can't really take me
seriously cuz I have a dangling but she be caught noodle is here to tell you
but just let things play out stop put your keyboard down don't do post just
watch me play doom with my dangling out okay okay give me a hug come on come
here give me a hug oh my arm is bigger
oh I need I need to pin everything in the right spot come here give give your
uncle she be a hug give me a hug
thank you for the doll no I've got one more shift to work in a week off so
party at my place we're gonna have potato salad goat cheese and mushroom
risotto and she be live she in 24 7 also thank you for the good times madam I
try yeah don't ask me why I have these items beside me these are methods of
torture these are instruments of torture I have beside me I'm gonna shove the
monster can up your ass then the maracas are next and then the guns in
your mouth you like that don't you I bet then I'm gonna teabag you
why is it so fun for me
why is it so fun for me try sexual are you at that are you attracted to tricycles
I don't explain anyways let me move these wait can I make my body out of
something else I have an idea sorry it's a tree tree be is gone oh wait what
about this can I do this
right
this is looking my body is this look like my body this ignore the purple
behind just ignore that but pretend that this is my body looks like I have a
neck I have a neck pillow looks like I swallowed someone they got stuck
army
what if I make my body
wait
Hold on, let me cook.
Let me cook.
Why is it so big?
Oh wait, I could be a kitty bread.
Hold on, I'm still cooking.
I'm just loafing around.
Pickle sheebie.
I need something for feet.
These be feet.
Hold on, no not me.
Hold on, let me cook.
Hold on, hold on.
Hold, hold.
It's like those little shoes.
I'm like a transformer.
Except, not really.
These are my feet.
I'm working on my hands.
She wants to play sport.
I've never played sport.
Oh wait, I have an idea.
Oh my god, why is that so huge?
No, that'll look like a turkey if I put these on my feet.
So I'll put this on my head.
Cause, and there's a reason.
I can't make it myself smaller.
Aha!
Actually, wait.
Hold on, I have a better idea.
I turned them.
They'll look like little nubs.
Thank you for the 10 gifted.
Thank you.
10 gifted.
I'm here all week.
Alright, what do you think?
Do you like my new body?
It's not as good as the noodle.
But it's pretty decent.
I would have been better if I put the bread over the whisk.
I'm a bread nugget.
If you like squint your eyes, just like squint them for me.
Just like really squint, squint, squint them.
Then it kind of, or like go cross-eyed, then it kind of works.
I'll be not afraid.
I'm stretching.
Raina, no, you're stinky.
Get off of me.
You need to clean your bum.
Now I'm sheebie noodle bread.
I mean, I'm sheebie cotton bread.
Sheebie cotton bread.
Goodnight.
Thank you.
Does this mean I'm baked?
Is this what the kids mean when they say they're baked?
Am I baked enough?
Am I baked up?
Smack my bitch up.
Wow!
Bop, bop, bop, bop, bop.
Smack my bitch up.
I'm ready to be.
La, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la.
Should I use cake?
Like I said, it's cake.
Wait, hold on, I got you.
I got you.
This is why strong he hired me. I don't
Cuz I'm making stuff out of free assets I'm making a
How do you like me do you like my form
I'm creative wow everybody's so creative
All right, let's play doom like this. Oh wait, I have an idea
I'm doing it one-handed. I look like a scary monkey
Am I a monkey
Perhaps
Monkey
You are monkey
Everything returns to monkey
Look, I followed the recipe to achieve and now it's getting sent in his streaming. I don't know what to tell you
Thank you, you're like
It's sad because I'm not drunk. It's sad that I'm doing this sober I
Was being racist
I
Look like a monkey with a gaming controller
My you're the one with an actual monkey Sona, okay
Now the vodka the vodka was gone when I accidentally turned into a swastika I
Didn't mean to that was literally I wasn't even trying to do a bit. I literally attached the tail and I was like fuck
The vodka is staying up the vodka the vodka stays
People are gonna click and expect do me turn all and they're just gonna get this fucking shit show
It's hidden in plain sight
They can't cancel me if they don't know where to find it
It wasn't my intention guys. I'm not a fucking Nazi
I swear to fucking God I'll fucking kill you if you fucking think I'm a Nazi like for real
I
Color palette is similar to it is similar to what your monkey self your monkey Sona
Mari go to bed is past your bedtime go play with some building blocks
Go to your homework, I don't think you even have homework yet cuz I don't think you've started school
Play with your iPad
Just don't though you can go play some Roblox or something. Oh, yeah
I said we have to schedule the freaking Roblox collab dude. Can you like
Can you can you can you message discord and are you about that by the way?
Thank you smooches kisses you
Okay, Friday 10 p.m. Okay cool cool cool
I have a collab on Monday possibly and if I just need any to confirm and then I have a collab on Friday
I don't know what to do up. No, we still haven't done my fucking schedule for this week guys. Help me
Help
Wait, did she say Monday hold on I can't
Why are you telling on me to try and Toma?
What is it? Okay
Yeah, okay
Why are you posting a fucking cockroach? Oh my god
It's literally you when you were a bug Nori
What's today
Wait, I'm so confused am I looking at the wrong all baby a triple
$3.33 I need some bread. Let's get this bread
Come on boys. Let's attain that green attain that green boys
Okay, I'm gonna put oh it's chain together. Oh, okay, can I copy this?
Oh, not as a Google Calendar. How do I just copy someone's thing? How do I just I just copy
Chains
Eeby
together
with
Amy
And
Secret or Dacted
Yep, it's iron mouse. You heard it here. No, I'm kidding. We're not clubbing iron mouse. That'd be funny
I'll be so fucking funny
She would never want to hang on this. Oh
What do I do Tuesday, I also have to have a member stream
Maybe
Maybe maybe after that collab do she be
Remember really watch along Monday scary movie three
I
Mean I put that there. I can't see the chat
No, why does it sound like I'm doing a machine on Tuesday
Wednesday the 28th what
I think you guys are telling me what day it was I
Just realized the second VTubers burps I've rated if I had a nickel for every this happened at two nickels
Which is much but weird it happened to it. It's not weird. Just watch any veeler member and we all just burp a lot
The game down. No, it's not gonna download because
Sorry, I'm threatening I'm threatening Mario indians. Um, because if I'm streaming it's not gonna be able to download at the same time
No, I get the reference I know the reference
I'm just
Denying the reference. I'm just I'm ignoring it and I'm saying you should have six nickels
I'll give you a nickel if you tickle my pickle
I
Anyways, um, so what should we do Tuesday boys?
Should we actually do doom do maternal on Tuesday on cheese that unit
Hi madam occasionally may need to clear the download cache for steam it improves download speed and fixes a lot of problems
People get with downloads. It may make you restart the download, but this normally helps. Thank you
I appreciate that information. However, it is not relevant because when I stream my internet goes crazy
And I get really terrible upload speeds while I'm trying to download something
So that's why I'm not actively trying to download do me eternal for an hour and 40 minutes
Because that's the remainder
While I'm streaming
Yes
Any whore, thank you for the stupa. I hope you like my jiggly pudding titties
You say Valorant
Mari I'm not fucking playing Valorant if I didn't have already a collab with you and some other people I would play Valorant with you
But I would have three collabs in one week and I'm gonna die if I do that
Sometimes I see to hang out with my boys, okay
Don't don't judge me. I still have a cookie left over
Next week the week after no, I have to what do you mean like the week after next week?
Did you meet guys mean this Friday
For the collab
Mariam can do we mean this Friday on set 10 p.m. For the
Roblox we're doing a Roblox collab spoiler
Mac can you put in dates can I forget?
I
I'm so sorry, please apologize. Can you can you take off your headphones? Let me speak to your wife
Can I can I please talk to your wife tell me when I'm on
September 6th, okay
But I'm alive
That was disgusting um, I wasn't even a good burp
That was terrible, why are you guys rating it that high that was like a seven. Yeah, okay see see sevens
Yeah, six. I understand that that was demonic
Excuse me
Excuse me. I'm raising my hand sir. Please. Can you please put your wife on the phone?
I'm not even joking. I want to speak to her. I will George
George put your wife on I
Want to get her in call
Well, not in call, but like unmute I'm like take off your headphones and play me from your speakers. I promise I'll be nice
Tell me when you're ready
I am I on the speaker am I am I am I on
Can she hear me
Excuse me George S's wife, I apologize for my appearance. I
Assume you are amazing and lovely
And you should leave him for me
Wouldn't you like to date this voluptuous bread body I
Can treat you so much better instead of being a man who watches really weird vTubers online
Let me wine and dine you I have delicious gelling pudding boobies
That is it, I hope you have a wonderful night evening day or morning
You know you miss a hundred percent of the shots you don't take gentlemen
How'd she my shot?
That's the one that the worst comes
Why be with the man who watches me or vTubers when you can be with the weird vTuber I
Have three cats
They're nice
They call me mr. Steele your wife. Mm-hmm
They got there she be cut then read
Are you raised
Did I burp I don't even realize it
Yeah, I got the whole bakery
People always ask me if my daddy's a baker cuz I'm such a cutie pie
I think I think our fellow harlot with the wife is on delay
I think he's all I think he's a little bit behind
All right
Miss George's wife trust me madam is a catch I am I
Am but only if you can catch me
Catch me if you can I'm the gingerbread man
My pudding just bounces around
My pudding my pudding my pudding not your pudding
I'm stalling because I'm scared to play the next level
I
Let us commence
I'm not drunk Mari
I'm gonna post a gif of me strangling her
Strangle gif
Perfect
Anyways back to the game
Now I'm in my monkey form my butt my my my my chef putting bread monkey form
Chai's just saying she loves us
Okay, Chai's really cute I love you to Chai
You are lovely Mari, however
Okay me focus now I'm tipsy because I feel sleepy. That's how I know I'm getting tipsy
All right, let's go boys
Can you can you do can you believe you got two Kino streams today? Can you believe that?
My god, you know
you know
Oh
The fricker Rooney
I feel like I've been here before
I
Fucking yellow keys man all my homies hate yellow keys
I might die
If I could
Oh
What the fuck bro
Please
Oh my god, I found the yellow key card
Guys I found the yellow key card. I have five percent health, but I found the yellow key card
I'm just gonna shoot and assume I'm gonna kill the person that's shooting at me
And you like have some health
Hell
How am I supposed to see the blue health bottle on the fucking floor when it's like that?
What's that?
Okay, have it
This is very tron music-esque I
Need a red key. Oh my god, I'm gonna cry
Oh, I thought that was the yellow door just kidding. It's literally right where I came from before
I
Have infinite range as well because that would be great
What is that
I'm just trying to focus on finding health right now
Yeah
Oh
Shooting at me
What is this
Do I have a fucking rocket launcher
Do I have a freaking rocket launcher
Who do I shoot with this I'm going the wrong way
What
Oh my god, bro
Did I just go back to the beginning that's literally where I came from wasn't it what
What on earth
How did I get over there before
Okay, I'll take that I go that way. No, I go this way
Yeah, oh get actually destroyed
That hurt me
Oh
I haven't been able to see the chat this entire time what the heck happened to you guys you guys left me
How could you leave me like this?
I
Was looking at the chat I couldn't see it cuz it was tabbed out
We were dropped on the wow Mari's just fucking telling me I was dropped on my head I was is so what
My mom said I came out with a cone head
And I had to wear like no, I didn't have to wear a helmet
They had a spoon with my head down I came out pointy
Anyways
Wait did I lose all my stuff did I lose what I lost everything
How are you still alive? Usually if I shoot you twice you're done
Mama llama
I
Matter fucking
I don't have the little key. I don't know why I'm trying to open it
Stop stop
Why aren't you daddy yet
Jesus
Christ
Guys I got a little key card are you proud?
That hurt me jumping down from this small fucking height is that why they say he doesn't have any kneecaps
I
Yeah, it takes a lot from a pistol
Something shooting at me that guy shooting at me
Mmm
Ah, it's another one, okay now I have a shotgun
No, am I gonna die here again
You
Like my girl
Okay
Ah, what's how's that song go that I see covered
So here we fucking go
X3 you are nos little crashy. Oh you you're so warm
So I did something something from across the floor
It's nice to freak it a bit to get the dynamite thing than than don't
There is a platypus he's rabid
Why my bread why don't you give me some head? Oh
How about that bitch
Okay
Ouch
I was about to say we're gonna play it safe, but then I got a fucking shot hit by the dude so
I have amazing range. Oh, what the frick, where did you come from brother?
I have no sense of direction
Oh
Usually he falls down
Hmm
Oh
Where where
Roger Roger
How do I change? How do I change?
I know I changed my weapon
Oh
Thank you
I did it
Wait before I go over there because I keep dying over there
Oh
Yeah, buddy
I found you bitch
What I thought there's a visible dude
What is that the noise
Is something trying to shoot me
Wait something open
I hear something opening. Oh what the hell
Oh
You got the shotgun
What's opening
I'll never know
And it wasn't it just up here yeah, it was
Yeah, it was number keys. Jump down
Please
Now I gotta go and retrace my steps
Trace my steps
Ah
Oh, I should have done that
To close proximity boys something itchy in my eye
Ah
I got him
What the fuck is that noise
I need a blue key. Where's the red door?
This is becoming too elaborate
I wish I would tell me when I used a key because I can't tell if I've been someplace already unless there's enemies there
I bet someone was able to get doom on tamagotchi. You could easily play doom on tamagotchi
This is where I fucking came from but fuck it. Let's retrace our steps
How the hell I'm getting motion sick
A blue key
I guess I don't need that
Yeah, I love doom eternal. It's great. This is the best doom game
That's better than the original
Could I put my silly eyes on? What are my silly eyes? Oh
I can't put my silly eyes on because
um
It's attached to my body. I don't have a I don't have
Oh, oh my god
Oh, I can
I
Be not afraid
All right, all these eyes are staying on for the rest of stream
How long have I been streaming for?
Oh
About two hours. All right, we'll continue
Okay
I've already been here
Hugging the walls for any secrets, okay, where do I need to go I need to go this way
I
Ain't a blue key for that
Really just looking for doors it's over here
Well, no
It's a wall
Man, it's over here
The heck it's showing like there's something it like it's a path. Oh, I just cleaned the districts itself
I picked up an armor bonus didn't even mean to
Picked up a stimpact didn't even mean to where am I?
I'm back at the start
I'm trying to navigate with just the
Okay, I found the room
Guys, I found it. I found the room
Really if I just hug like if I just go through the map like that I can find the things I don't
Get that at all, but it works for me
Uh now if I could remember where the blue room was
Okay, well we're gonna do it again
Anyways
It's hard to control
Can I please go down the hallway? Thank you
Oh, that's the restart
Okay
Wait what oh, what the hell
Where did you come from I don't they just spawn another guy randomly. All right, here we are
I
Made it boys
Oh it's over there
Oh
Can I jump out this window and get that stuff please how's anyone supposed to get over there
What's that
Found the exit
Yippie
Wow, I'm so talented
This is my special outfit
I really go to this game it said par three and I did 1310 so I tripled it
Triple
That's three times three
I quadrupled it
It's a world record
More than quadruple
Oh, baby. I tripled
This is my cute and funny form this is this
Is
This is my
This is a conny model everyone's been waiting for
Do you like my proportions how many apples high am I?
My brother see
Am I am I uo enough?
Two apples she's been
I am dominant and breadable
What happens if I do this
Oh
I was trying to see if I could cry from this why am I
So
But wait my eyes just look
I
Wiggling my eyebrows, can you guys see it? Can you guys see that I was wiggling my eyebrows?
The rizzles working
Yippie
I
I'm yippie. I don't want to play more Elden Ring too, but I shouldn't like my model. Thank you. Is my 2.0
Who needs to spend money when you have stuff like this, you know, this is all free assets
That still tastes bad
Downgrade this is an upgrade. What are you talking about brother?
Is this the final boss
Um guys I'm in a box
Why would anyone
I
Was a desert fucking level
Wait
Oh
Mars is essentially one big desert you're not wrong. Oh, give me
Where do I feel like there's another room and I'm just blind was there a room over here? Why is this wall of fake?
I'm going insane
Okay, I went in this room and grabbed that stuff. I'm getting that stuff
All right
What the hell is what
What's the matter? What's the matter?
What is this?
Oh my god, I'm gonna I'm in lava
Ah
He's flexing on me
Time to lock in brothers it's time to lock in
Can I like peaceful up the barrel
Oh, so that was a thing there why didn't I
See it before that was weird
At least they give you everything very very understanding
Rada rada
Okay boys
Let's do this thing
Okay
This is such a bad area to fight in I like
Oh, I'm not on lava
I
Can lead on them over here. Where's the other guy?
Come over here
Oh
Damn it
Let's go
Now what
Oh
Hello
Is that a pentagram sick
Once you beat the big badasses and clean out the moon base you're supposed to win aren't you
Aren't you where's your fat reward and take it home?
What the hell is this it's not supposed to end this way
It stinks like rotten meat
But it looks like the lost deep damos base
Looks like you're stuck on the shores of hell
The only way out is through to continue the doom experience
Play the shores of hell in its amazing sequel inferno
That's very good
Bake bread baker doko
My eye itches I would have spent good money on this game
That's super cool 1,890 games
$40
Mastercard beast on americans press accepted ask about the hit manual
That's pretty is a baby sentry video
Wait hold on
Oh
I'm like one of the like hey melt hey bear. I'm a hey bear my hey bear sentry video
And you guys like stream today
I had a dream like this once
She bred in the ship at
Wait I should sing a song
That's the fruit dancing the videos are the hey bear baby sentry videos. They're really fun to watch by the way
Don't ask me why
One of my friends has a baby and I went over
To help babysit and I just sat and watched hey bear and miss rachel with her for
Like two hours
Well, this was fun
Did uh did you enjoy
Keep dancing like that chat's gonna crumble should I should I
Should I show that wait I just realized my cherries were gone
Oh they're back now I have nipples
Oh
What is it hold on can you can you just look at this?
Do you like
I
Do
The doom eternal not work out. No, we played doom. I don't know what gave you that idea
that do me that doom didn't work out. I don't I don't know what gave you that idea. I have
no idea. Anyway. Well, that's it. There's nothing left. I hope you enjoyed stream
today. I think I had a great time. It was really fun playing doom and acting silly with
you. I hope that you have a good day or a good night. I feel bad if you've been stressed
the last past couple of days. I hope I was able to cheer you up a little bit because
that's all I want to do is make you happy and cheer you up and do funny stuff and seduce you.
But I care about you and I hope you have a good day and everything's gonna be okay.
Now, tell me you understand. Tell me. Tell me you understand.
Please continue to be positive and also be patient with us. Okay, all right. Don't look
at my cherries. Don't look at my cherries. My eyes are up here. Thanks for the motivation.
No problem. Of course. I hope you enjoy your rest out. Thank you for the soup. Good. Let me find
somebody to raid. Are you raiding in me? Yeah, we are. All right. I'm gonna say hello to my
little friend. My little sister, really. Yeah. Okay. It's called Monkey Wizard Raid. She's
playing Wizard 101 and I'm a monkey. All right. You got it. Good. Bye. I love you. Even if you're stinky.